[Musique]
je ne connais pas
une représentation théâtrale dans
l'hémicycle du conseil départemental pas
vraiment une première mais quand il
s'agit de lycéens venus de madagascar la
prouesse théâtrale est encore plus a
souligné l'équipe du théâtre du lycée
aéré vélo ramamonjy de fianarantsoa a
remporté le concours la troisième
édition de la compétition nationale de
france et c'est un concours
organisé par le projet le projet map m
madagascar appui à l'enseignement du et
en français le projet map et finance la
compétition par les pieds des
associations de professeurs de français
en 2016 ce sont soixante et un lycées
qui ont participé au concours qui vise à
favoriser la pratique de la langue
française une initiative soutenue par le
ministère de l'éducation elle gâche
l'ambassade de france du conseil
départemental et de l' agence
universitaire de la francophonie
oif jeu si son mari le père le pearl
rapide qui peut avoir que je fus il aime
pas mais j'aime son argent c'est pour ça
que j'ai déposé
le dit mais moi je suis la fille des
blanchisseuses
et je suis chez moi les jumelles mais ma
mère
[Musique]
de recettes via une pièce de théâtre qui
mêle humour situations caustique dans un
français impeccable qui a beaucoup plu
aux deux classes de collège pour mon
venu à la rencontre des lauréats du
concours
[Musique]
la patience
c'est super nabias d'origan
ça faisait rire
une rencontre qui a donné lieu à des
retrouvailles fortuite puisque une des
lycéennes malgache a retrouvé une
cousine réunionnaise
lui ai demandé si elle connaissait
jasmin et elle m'a répondu que c'était
sa cousine ce titre
je sais que j'ai de la famille ici à
saint denis le conseil départemental qui
apporte sa contribution l'apprentissage
du français air madagascar à travers la
mise à disposition depuis 2013
d'animateur de clubs français dans les
huit lycées publics malgaches
que tout le monde connaît plus ou moins
élevé c'est important que la
francophonie un rôle majeur dans l'océan
indien à côté des créoles chez nous mais
au delà de du crawl à la réunion il faut
effectivement que le français tout ça
presse dont le symbole est ce type de
manifestation
qui fait se rencontrer madagascar est là
les eaux à travers des jeunes lycéens
des jeunes collégiens est une excellente
initiative et l'on peut apprécier le
niveau de français déjà d'un gosse ça
pourrait effectivement lorsqu'on veut on
peut ce lien avec madagascar à travers
la francophonie et à travers donc ces
lycéens ces jeunes qui
une passion un amour puisque on en a
discuté encore avec eux pour la langue
française donc très important pour nous
la réunion île française dans l'océan
indien de tenir donc ce lien avec les
îles de l'océan indien et
particulièrement avec madagascar on est
très fiers énormément au piano
conditionnellement fier bien
la récompense pour ces lycéens non ce
séjour à l'île de la réunion
l'occasion de visiter les équipements
culturels du département au programme
les différents musées de la collectivité
mais également une journée à la
découverte de notre île et vous verrez
vous êtes ma mère
[Musique]